hey everybody let's see if i'm happy
with the framing this time or if i'm
going to
adjust the darn thing again like i
always do because
i'm picky and finicky like that hope
everyone's doing all right
it's been um it's been
it's been an odd sort of chunk of time
uh so normally um
i was gonna say normally around this
time let me adjust
this just a bit that's better
but normally um
around mid uh around mid-july or
sometimes around this time
i would have gone on a family vacation
with my daughter and her mother except
the place that we normally go for a
five-day vacation
is closed so captioning not
and it was pleasant available i got i
don't know if you can tell from my nose
uh mildly sunburnt and
thanks to the fact that all i have for
swimming
is a um is a swimming shirt
um i don't have a i don't have like a
bikini top or a tankini that i'm
comfortable in which means
after having avoided it the rest of the
summer i finally ended up with the
dang farmer's tan it cuts off right
there
i managed to get go without getting one
this far into the summer and then
end of july tell me have you ever danced
with the devil in the pale moonlight
i just asked that of all my prey i just
like the sound of it
tomorrow is my birthday so goes oh happy
birthday leprechaun master
that is an odd sentence for me to say
but i'm enjoying it
new hampshire pride yeah i like i like
new hampshire
i like it better now new hampshire new
hampshire was where i worked new
hampshire was
where the job that i didn't really like
and worked at for
almost 10 years that was in new
hampshire
how's tricks i'm i'm getting by i'm
doing okay
um still figuring stuff out still still
things the i'm
i'm feeling pretty i
i don't want to get over optimistic
because it's it's not
there yet but i feel like i have a shot
at getting things in a place
where this
well this in the patreon might actually
be my living
um i'm not there yet it's i'm i'm closer
than i'm
than i've ever been though like
tantalizingly close
we'll see what happens in the next few
months uh good day hope you're fearing
well
uh would life be interesting if we all
reverted to 16th century century bard
speech actual 16th century bard speech
no the uh the pop culture understanding
what oh
my fair lords and lasses and
all those betwixt yeah that'd be fun
i don't tan i burn yeah i bet
it's funny i shouldn't be able to tan as
far as
most of my um as far as most of my
lineage goes um
because i'm mostly english and a bit of
german
um but i actually do tan
and it's
it's gonna sound like a joke but i'm
serious i can
tan because an egyptian sailor got lost
i i have a bit of egyptian in me because
a sailor
ended up where he wasn't supposed to be
and that got in the mix and i can tan
when by all rights i should not be able
to
uh and i i don't want to claim that like
oh i'm part of this like i
i i know nothing about that end of like
heritage um but like i do know what's in
there
uh you have such a beautiful singing
voice you should do cover songs
i mean there's a couple reasons i don't
the first is like i don't have the
confidence in my singing voice
um to get through a whole song like if i
sing like you get little bits
from me because that's what i'm i'm
confident in especially without
accompaniment and i can't play an
instrument
um and then there's the other thing
which is stuff gets flagged
so fast it's ridiculous hello
i bring chicken nuggies
uh i love your doctor cosplay tick tock
just one question
can i be your new companion please i'm
taking applications
it's got it's got to be a vetting
process
uh so i didn't get cast in 12 angry men
but i have a therapist i'm seeing next
week i'm sorry you didn't get cast
uh that is a really fun show that's a
really cool show to get to be able to do
um but i hope your therapy goes well
castile
watchman has the most emmy nominations
this year i still need to
see it oops
found a new job yet hope you have i have
not
um i am looking i'm
i i i'm really i'm trying to find
something that is
a nine to five weekday job because you
know i do have my kid and she's starting
up school again i don't want something
that's going to bleed into evenings or
weekends so
you know and and i'm not gonna move so
the job market where i am is it's a
little tight
hope you had a good week yeah not too
bad
uh got a close tonight it ticked me off
because my boss
didn't even ask me if i could he just
rewrote the schedule so i'd close
tonight and tomorrow oh
fun those are fun bosses
loved your fixing ghostbusters video
what other films do you want to fix i
don't know
see the thing is the the the response
to that video was not dissimilar
to the response to the video i did
on the death of superman which is that
the people who
like who watched it really liked it
but the views were low versus what is
typical for me so it's hard to
justify doing that format again when it
didn't
yield that much view
you know subscriber revenue sort of
thing
that being said feasibly you could make
an argument that maybe would do better
with a more recent movie except movies
aren't really coming out right now and
most of the movies that i could think of
um or even seasons of television that i
can think of that i would want to do
are also way out of date
um so i
of the ones that i feel like i could
actually produce a script and a video on
i don't know if they do any better than
the ghostbusters 2
and then it just becomes a the amount of
work
compared to what it yielded question
um and it's the it's the sort of thing
like
um if if ev if my bills were firmly
covered where maybe i'd be more willing
to roll the dice but since i'm trying to
edge them up
to where my bills will be covered um i i
need to try and find things that
that land a little bit harder
ah backing up backing up backing up
questions are coming
are coming fast and i'm falling behind
already ah
let's see
success is within your gut thank you
carowind thank you very much
had a guy question my new bisexual pride
tattoo today
guess what it was and i said it's
because i'm a proud bisexual man
he said man can't be bi this stream
makes me feel better ah
god's sake bisexual erasure is one of
the most
frustrating things and it's one of the
most persistent things and the really
irritating thing is that it's very
persistent even within the lgbtq
community
like my my partner's bisexual and
but you know she's dating me and
prior to me her longest term you know
partner was
was a man and obviously with me it's
sort of an
odd thing but you know she dated
a guy for so long that the idea that she
was bisexual
threw people off and
[Music]
you know if they know she's dating me
they know okay
maybe there's something going on but
people don't clock her
as anything other than straight which
kind of annoys her on a on a fundamental
level
but um with bisexual here's the thing i
feel like
i feel like the stereotypical response
actually goes in opposite direction
directions i can speak
between men and women with women
who claim they're bisexual it's usually
chalked up to you're actually straight
you're going through a phase
and for men who claim to be bisexual
they get told
no you're just gay and don't want to
admit it
both of which are plausible
i'm not going to say neither of which
ever happens but is a really
nonsense response to give to somebody
but you hear it a lot
even still again like i
identify as pansexual although i lean
very heavily
towards um towards women and that
includes trans women
but you know i i also look the way i
look
so i don't think i don't think it throw
i'd since i don't
i'm not straight passing i'm not i'm not
straight cis passing anymore i don't
think it throws people off as much and
they're more prepared to believe that
i'm
just uh insane kinky sexual deviant
which you know
that's an unfair assumption it's true
but it's unfair
uh speaking of my username i was in a
bright green bowler hat
i am a redhead and a guy called me a
leprechaun a stranger
yes wow okay
uh i got the five volume
time of hitchhiker ooh sweet you fix
ghostbusters two will you fix anything
else
i mean like some of the things that are
on a list to maybe
consider fixing i'm trying to remember i
wrote some down
um ant-man and the wasp
was on that list off without my head i
can't remember what else was
there were some other things on there
suicide squad i put on the list but that
was a question mark because i don't know
if i could add
anything to it that folding ideas didn't
unpack
at least in terms of the describing
what's wrong i guess he didn't talk all
that much about how it could have been
done better just snip that was something
he touched on
snippets across it new patron alone
from scotland yard code named the doctor
yes i tweeted this to you i just wanted
to resay it because it was the first
thing i bought with my first paycheck
mwah
much appreciated thank you very much if
you're really close to doing this for a
living i've got some spare organs
waiting buying some scissors and tape
let's do this let's
maybe hold off on that step i'm mostly
english
uh quarter irish scots wells eight
percent scandinavian 20
20 greek interesting mixed pirates
uh did you do one of the dna tests no
actually i have um
i have a relative out in california who
like long before that was
a thing it did exhaustive genealogy
so like i know genealogy my genealogy
going back
an insanely far distance
um and like quite a quite a bit of it as
well
like i i cannot
again they're written down somewhere i
cannot remember off the top in my head
but i
i have relatives who came over on the
mayflower
uh so i am
i'm very much a new england wasp if
people don't know that
white anglo-saxon protestant
uh yeah that's that's my heritage by and
large
well thank you amanda might help you get
a wee bit closer
that is appreciated uh
you're funny when you do your drunk
reviews i have one of those on the
docket
and i have a couple of other things that
i if i watch they'd have to be
drunk reviews like if i watch fan four
stick
that's gonna be a drunk review
uh i don't care what it takes you will
sing doctor in distress one day
sing it i don't know i do still need to
watch it
uh opinions on orange is the new black
have you seen it i've seen the first two
seasons
i thought this first season was okay
second season was great
and everything i've heard about the
seasons after that i don't want to watch
it i don't care
so as far as i'm concerned it was a two
season show and ended fantastically
uh thank you for reminding me say hi to
your latest five dollar patreon sub
thank you so much
i've got so many names to update
in the um and the credits
because i i do that at the start of the
month because i wait for
um you know for everybody to be clear
from the month uh before before i do an
update and so that i'm not
also updating it continuously for every
video but
i've got i've got so many names to add
the the the credit scroll is gonna
go a lot faster to fit those all those
names in the same amount of time
and that's that is a good problem to
have and i'm happy to have it
it's kind of ironic that it took your
unemployment for your patreon to get a
high boost
it is funny how that worked out isn't it
hello nice to see your happy face love
the blue thank you
looks great on you i'm off to work now
hospital admin work is never done
we'll watch later well have a good uh
evening at work sammy gotten any further
with harley quinn season two no i
haven't started it yet
uh the new red dwarf and new trailer for
bill and ted oh
there was a new trailer i missed that um
has the new red dwarf hit brit box yet
that's what i'm waiting because i know
it comes
it's coming to that i haven't checked
lately see if it hit yet
so now we've seen what your doctor looks
like what would your master
look or be like i don't know
like that one i don't know i haven't
really thought about that
i really like your character analysis of
the fifth fifth doctor mr tardis
review says the fifth doctor is a good
man who constantly beats himself up
because he can't be a better one
that's an interesting perspective um and
i feel like
i um
like maybe next time i watch a fifth
doctor
uh story i'll try and watch it with that
in mind
uh what is your tick tock handle it's at
vera wilde
um i just got my first pride flags bi
and gender fluid and love them lovely
very nice
uh please can you react to doctor in
distress i plan to
when i watch it i will have a camera set
up it'll be a reaction
it'll be a thing fixing batman vs
superman
no no like
i i would not be able to banish
um movie bob's epic
like god all together probably four
hours
worth of dissection of that from my mind
and he even included like things that he
would do to make it better so
i i don't trust myself to be able to
come up with suggestions that wouldn't
be
influenced by what he did um so that one
definitely not
um one of my friends is a little jealous
because she read
the last of my the last script for my
audio spin-off and another character has
better lines
than her that can happen
sometimes when you do projects for
friends you get the script you go oh you
you wrote me a crap part i wanted this
part like
yeah i've i've i've been there a little
not like
was written for but i've been in like
plays directed by friends who
you didn't cast me on the part i wanted
and i like i got over it but
you know i've been there uh do you
listen to any stand-up if so favorite
comedian mullaney for me mullaney's very
good
i don't listen to a lot of recent stand
up um the most recent stand up that i
have listened to
is john mulaney and hannah gadsby
i mean i grew i grew up on george carlin
absolutely loved georgetown i like him
up until um
about the late 90s getting into the
2000s
he lost me a little bit he sort of i
feel like he he just he got a little too
angry
for my taste not without cause i got why
but i didn't enjoy his work as much at
that point
a favorite character from each
arrowverse show okay
there's some arrowverse shows i've only
ever watched for the crossovers and
there's some i still haven't seen
but of the ones i've seen at least some
episodes of
um arrow i liked felicity
i've only ever seen the crossover
crossover episodes for that
um for uh flash it was
uh iris's dad i only watched the first
two seasons of that so i can't remember
his name now
um legends of tomorrow
probably mick um
and then black lightning i need to get
back into
i did i only did a few episodes i didn't
really pick a favorite
um supergirl actually right now it's lex
luthor
i'm working my way through season four
i'm loving this lex luthor
uh and then what else is there batwoman
i haven't seen
i'm probably forgetting something
there's this too many of these dang
shows
not sure if i missed it or seen it on a
previous live stream
but i'm curious what is on your necklace
oh this is um
robin from season three of stranger
things
um liz got got we got
matching ones and we sometimes trade off
with them so
there's robin and there's steve both in
there
um their outfits from
scoops ahoy i think it was uh you know
they're sort of nautical nerd
outfits um so
we each have one of those i have a
transgender symbol
tattooed on my ribs so i can hide it if
needed what are your thoughts on visible
stuff like that
i'd say power to you i mean you're also
asking somebody who has no tattoos
visible or otherwise so
i'm not necessarily sure i'm the best
opinion to get
um but i power to you
sorry to bring this up and won't mind if
you don't want to answer oh boy
do you think they'll make more fantastic
beasts warner brothers want
the money but you know who has got
creative control
here's the thing because
jk rowling and yes i'm going to say her
name she's not she who must not be named
she's not no
she's a human being i'll use her name
she's a human being who i'm insanely
frustrated with but
i'm not going to treat her like a super
villain
jk rowling hasn't just made this a thing
that she said once she's made this a
crusade
she's made this a thing she keeps saying
a cause that she has taken up
and a position that she has decided to
keep doubling down on
over and over and over and over again so
this puts water brothers in a very tough
situation
because normal um
executive logic would be wait for things
to blow over
but the thing is it's not going to blow
over
because
she's not gonna stop talking
and what that means for them is
they are going to i mean yes they still
want the money
they're not just gonna let the
[Music]
um rights lapse they'll do whatever they
have to do to hold on to them because
you need to realize warner brothers has
so much more has money sunk into so much
more than just the movies all the merch
is merch related to the films not the
books
so um they've got a lot of money tied up
in that franchise
but they're in a position where normally
what they would want to do
is distance themselves from her but they
can't because of the amount of
her the amount of control
that she still exerts on that uh on that
property and the fact that she wrote the
last two scripts which i probably
i think they probably wouldn't have
wanted her to do but she had the
authority to be able to do that
so i think they're gonna have a very
hard time getting another one
off the ground i think if they do it
they're going to want to do it a
vastly reduced budget i think they're
going to have a hard time getting eddie
redmayne back it's going to
depend on the wording of contracts as to
whether or not they can force him to
come back or not
if they can they'll probably want to
negotiate jk rowling into an advisory
role and not actually writing the script
itself
they may or may not have the ability to
do that again depending on contracts
i don't know like i i honestly don't
know at this point now that said
if another one gets made i'm not going
to watch it
i'm just not and it for me it's
it's more than just my
ticket goes towards supporting her
financially
and lending to her clout
and power knowing how she is now
choosing to wield it
i don't want
to see harry potter stuff
i hope that i will again at some point
but right now i just don't
uh i won't be going to see it if they do
um rowling will be distraught to find
out she's lost my personal support yes
i'm sure she will
i actually keep forgetting that my older
sister is pansexual even though she's
married to a guy
i mean like when someone's in a
long-term relationship
for for quite a significant amount of
time with one person you tend to think
oh that's what they
are so you know if in the case of your
sister if she's married to a man you
think oh she's straight but i mean
her interests in other
genders don't go away just because she
decided to be monogamous with a guy
but like i get it optics you keep seeing
her with this guy and so like
that's kind of how your brain tries to
simplify life
but life isn't simple so that's
something that the human brain does that
kind of works against us
uh
let's see survival is revenge at this
point
um yeah i can feel that way sometimes
uh if they're releasing the snyder cut
of justice league do you think they'll
do the same with all the cut footage
from suicide squad
um no i don't think they can because the
thing is there
isn't well let me reword this
i wouldn't put it past warner brothers
to try and market
a director's cut of suicide squad the
thing is
they they are not going to throw the
money behind it to do what they're doing
with justice league because you need to
understand
suicide squad was changed
the significant parts of the script were
changed at the last
minute on very short notice and that's
part of why
the movie was such a mess it
i haven't rewatched in a long time but
it very much feels like a movie that was
shot with the intention of
figuring out what the movie was in the
edit but then the edit
was taken away from the director and it
was re-edited
by three different groups and then
mashed up into the monstrosity that we
ended up with
but one kind of presumes that what the
raw footage they were working with
probably didn't fit together all that
coherently anyways
so and i don't think there's as much a
call
i don't think people feel like they were
robbed of a great suicide squad movie
at least i i mean maybe there are if
there are they're not as loud as the
snyder cup people they just
aren't i think i'm half scottish oh
lovely
my father's a genealogist very cool any
lgbt
uh precedence in your past not that i
know of off the top my head
probably but not not that i know of
apparently i'm descendant um from gypsy
so god knows where i'm from
fair enough heathers are mean girls i've
never seen heathers
there's a lot of stuff from the 80s i
missed
according to my dad i'm related to
american artist norman rockmelt
rockwell ooh cool uh
puts down scissors throws them throws
them away from morgan's
god you're worse than my dad
need a drinking partner always um
thank you very much uh iong has
i feel like i've asked you how to
pronounce that before and i've now lost
it
um do you worry that to build the
channel further
you might need to go negative for the
buzz hits please don't
um i don't want to
like you like i've known for a while
negative stuff gets more views than
positive i'm
well aware of that like i've had the
metrics to back that up for at least
three years
that i know that for a fact and when i
feel i have
something that i need to say that is
negative i will say it but i'm not going
to construct
you know deliberately try and construct
things to be negative for the sake of
trying to grow the channel faster
because i'd be growing it on the back of
stuff that i don't want to do
and that's not healthy for me
would you consider making how to fix it
videos on doctor who episodes
uh you basically do that in some reviews
uh but could become part of the other
series
is like i'm
the one that came to mind
would possibly be how to fix series
seven
because the problems of series seven are
pretty unique and it's also a series
that pretty much everyone agrees
does not work and is clunky there's some
disagreement on
where it fails some people feel the
second half is better some people people
feel the first half is better
but the fact that it is two distinct
halves that don't
join smoothly one to the other is
obviously a problem
i'm not promising that because i haven't
thought on it long enough
to figure out if i have a take
that is worth talking about
what i consider it yes i am
uh i just got a doctor who mystery box
what do you think i'll get i don't know
what i'd love to hear
uh when is the time lord victoria's
coming out september last i knew
um if they moved anything forward i
didn't catch that
um
i am so far behind sorry give me a
second
uh
wow holy cow i'm so far behind on
questions
my great grandfather had a family tree
he wrote up said we were mainly
bulgarian turns out it was
fake we were mainly irish and scottish
no wonder so many of us are alcoholics
uh
the thing is like i've got genealogy
backed up on both sides of my family
because
i've got the same relative on both sides
of my family
like it's so far back it doesn't matter
but you remember how i mentioned i have
uh relatives who came i had a relative
who came over in the mayflower
yeah it's the same relative on both
sides of my family
so my family tree is a wreath
it rejoins quite a ways back
again like it's so far back that it's
meaningless
but yeah so i've i've got
the i've got the i've got at least up to
the mayflower
connection um backed up by genealogy
done
on both sides of my family by different
people
uh first stream i've watched of yours
thanks for all the awesome work thank
you alice nice to have you here
uh you wouldn't look like the master uh
for i am the master and you will obey me
is that what you've got shouting no
call me master
okay uh so listen review tomorrow in my
opinion the most overrated episode
certainly of new who
i actually don't know what the popular
opinion of listen is anymore
i know it was a pretty it was pretty
well like when that one aired i don't
know what people think right now
how much would we have to bribe you to
get you watch doctor indus
in distress live um
i don't know if i could figure out how
to do it live i think you're gonna have
to settle for a reaction
uh how to fix batman versus superman
turn off the screen
yeah that would do it have you heard of
the holo on netflix i have not
i don't know if this was commented but
dipper is a cool character because he's
12 but tries to act 16.
that's why at some points he's selfish
because he's trying to grow up faster i
get that but you know i'm an adult
that's a that's an
angle that doesn't connect with me as
well
uh loved your ghostbusters 2 video i
normally hate how to fix video but i
enjoyed yours oh
thank you that's great fixing the
timeless child
simple make it anyone other than the
doctor
that's it uh it's not that she doesn't
like her part
she loves it but i gave the other
character all the better one-liners oh
the snappy bits yep
uh ever played a pokemon game i played a
very small amount of pokemon yellow
in like 2000
any advice for setting up something like
an online table read for a script in
terms of how best to make it accessible
or pleasant for people i mean my
recommendation would be zoom
at this point you know i've done um i've
done video conferencing over a bunch of
apps from skype to discord to zoom zoom
has been the most reliable by a
heavy margin so um
i would recommend that and i mean if
you're asking how to conduct
a table read i just
make sure everyone has a script no
they're know their parts and that
somebody's there to read out the um
you know the direction parts
do you think knew who could pull off a
black and white episode if
so any suggestions of what the story
would be like um
they probably could i'd have to think
about it though
assuming they have cats how many lives
does a gallifreyan cat have
um well theoretically
it would be
uh a hundreds seventeen
yeah i've watched dr horrible sing along
blog
uh and iris's dad's name joe joe yes
thank you
um yes i've watched dr hartwell sing a
long blog i haven't rewatched it in a
long time
um but i have seen it by the way you
need to be drunk to watch doctor in
distress
just an advisory warning we'll see when
we get there
um doom patrol uh complete with cosplay
hmm i'm curious now
i finished season two of angel i'm just
so annoyed i'll never see
drusilla properly again i've already
finished buffy
i do like drusilla i don't love her as
much as some people but i do enjoy her
my grandmother had a tattoo of blackpool
tower up her back with the words kiss me
quick
next to it wow that's you had an
interesting grandmother
next performance uh you should do never
going to give you up and just turned 26
yesterday
uh no the the thing is though i do
have um i do have a deep enough voice to
be able to do that song
like i i've gotten used to
[Music]
sort of finding the middle ground
between you know with my voice at this
point
um because if i deliberately pitch it up
it ends up a bit more up here
um so i kind of settle in around here
but i can bring it down
never gonna give you up never gonna let
you down
can't sing any more than that cause
don't wanna get
demonetized again
uh reviewing shakespeare code that's
another one i haven't rewatched and
don't really want to for
obvious reasons um
being backed by norm chomsky isn't a
good cure for hubris
i think i missed something on that one
jk's latest attack leaves no doubt she's
just misinformed but trying to do good
see the thing is
she does she thinks she knows
and that and that's what makes what
she's doing so hazardous she
she believes she's right and she
believes she knows what she's talking
about
and that's
that's what's kind of depressing about
it
my harry potter and fantastic beasts
blu-rays are currently
hidden out of sight at the back of my
wardrobe
fair favorite feral movie i don't really
like will ferrell
um i mean my favorite movie that he was
in
is probably lego movie if you want a
movie that like he stars in
i suppose probably stranger than fiction
i don't really like will ferrell
all that much uh what do you think about
aliens three
um i would like it if they didn't kill
newt
and that's a very easy fix to do just
have ripley's
crowd to be the only one that's
compromised and the only one ejected
and then newt and hicks stay on board
the
ship and they fly off and she crash
lands as opposed to having them all
crash
land killing hicks who i don't care
about and killing newt who i do care
about because that invalidates the
entire climax of the previous film
i mean that is a massive original sin i
have a hard time forgiving the film for
if i remove that fact from my mind it's
not bad
it's pretty good even i'm also one of
the weirdos that thinks the theatrical
cut is better than the assembly cut
i think i just like it because it's
tighter
uh what did jk rowling do the only thing
i heard was that she did
was pretty bad oh boy okay
as short as i can jk rowling has taken
a very anti-transposition while claiming
to not be against trans people which
really infuriates me because people will
go but she says she likes trans people
weren't you reading yes i read the whole
thing as opposed to just that one
sentence she
um she has latched on
to all of the worst
myths about trans people
especially trans youth if you want a
full breakdown
i would recommend going to jimmy dodgers
youtube uh he and his fiancee do an
excellent breakdown
point by point of everything wrong
with her position so if you want a full
breakdown of what she said and why it's
wrong
that's where i would recommend going
vince gilligan said even though he
created the world of breaking bad he
doesn't want to oversee
his welcome in the world itself i think
all authors need to do this including
uh oh he didn't want to overstay his
welcome i think all authors need to do
this including rolling
um well i mean
it's hard to compare the two because
breaking bad isn't
franchisable the way
um the way
that harry potter is
and not to mention like i don't know
vince gillian a ton but like to my
understanding like he had been working
in television for a while
harry potter was jk rowling's first book
first published work
so you know he has a he has a background
in working in something letting it go
and then doing something else
even though she's written other stuff
she's never had to let go of harry
potter
and that was the first thing she ever
did and that's probably part of the
reason why she doesn't want to
uh reviewing shakespeare code a few
lines hit differently with more recent
knowledge of gareth roberts like martha
pointing out men dresses woman the
doctor replies london never changes
yeah i think you left that in a comment
um
yeah that was that was rough
i'm not uh too bothered when you did did
it but i just wanted to check remember
my accession commission i do remember
um it is a little bit further back in
line the
the what i'm working on reading right
now is a graphic novel volume
[Music]
then i think yours is the next book
that's up i also have a lot of video
and movie reviews that have been
commissioned but i think
after i get through the graphic novel
i'm on yours is the next book
that i that i have scheduled to do
excuse me
also the jk rowling reference to
shakespeare code is a lot more tragic
now oh yeah
oh yeah super chat mess no i i caught it
but
i'm so far behind um
which hamilton character would you
cosplay as i don't care
i just want one of those jackets those
coats are awesome
would you rather see the doctor who
episodes stephen hawking
stephen hawkins or albert einstein
neither i mean if you're going to make
me pick one i suppose stephen hawkins
um because they've actually had einstein
appear
it was in a minisode but they did him
already
do you enjoy jar jar i kind of do i
really don't uh
are you going to buy any of the new
doctor who action figure sets that's
just released
no i'm not really an action figure
person like i'm a
i'm a souvenir person but also a lot of
this stuff is gifts
i'm not really an action figure person
so much at this point like i'll admire
them
i'll enjoy them it's not something i
spend my own money on too much
tweeted your video to dan aykroyd yet to
get a response yeah
i don't expect you will but thank you
for trying
um oh dang it it jumped down to the
bottom again so now i gotta scroll
all the way back up um
if you watch doctor in distress the
sheer power of the negativity will make
you the most viewed thing ever
finished broadchurch series 2 over the
weekend it's really good and worth
checking out
nowhere near the almost perfection of
the first but good fun and performances
um i mean i i thought the first series
was decent
everything i've heard is that the next
two aren't as good and so
that's kind of my incentive to not
bother
maybe a dan accurate interview for
patreon
uh like i'm so bad at networking
you guys it's not even funny you folks
i still use guys that in my head is
gender neutral i'm still trying to get
out of that habit still still
years later underrated part of series
7's first half is how
the intros changed with the episode i
personally
liked it uh and yes you're very behind
yeah have you ever watched clue starring
tim curry christopher lord i grew up on
clue i love clue one plus two plus two
plus one
uh wait if your family tree is a wreath
does that mean there's incest in your
family tree
well yes that was what i was implying
but again it's like
16
[Music]
so so far back that no i don't think
that counts as incest
uh not in any practical sense
um head bowed oh
good girl finished broadchurch series
two oh i did that
uh i hated the mt child episodes because
uh episode horrified me when i watch it
when i was
seven rewatched it five years later love
it
those are fantastic episodes that but
that that kid is creepy
and it's great that delivery of call me
master that smile
is this fear or attraction ideally it's
both
i am no jedi nice
i've got i unfortunately i don't have
the lightsaber to hand that didn't come
down with everything else lightsabers up
in my bedroom
uh have you seen doctor in address it's
so fun in parody
parodies uh the nmds the lyrics with
doctor and address save us from this pc
mess oh dear
uh are you going to review onward i did
you need to go to the break room of
geeks
for that one that's my secondary channel
but yes i i reviewed that
uh which carowind told you so sorry if
i'm kind of out of the loop on your
reviews of late however what is your
opinion of red dwarf the promised land
haven't seen it yet i'm waiting for it
to hit brit box in the u.s
okay it's being mentioned so much now i
need to watch
the doctor in distress according to
stories and some records my scottish
clan
uh mckinnis can be traced back to the
earliest days of scottish history so
chuffed
nice if canine was the doctor's robot
dog
would velyne be the doctor's cat
oh that was terrible congratulations
are you going to do a series review of
watchmen in one video or website
by episode reviews uh it'll be a it'll
be a series
because if i'd gotten to it while it was
airing i would have done episode by
episode but
it'll be serious unless something
happens we're like i need to talk about
like make the first half before i unpack
the second like
that's not impossible
unpossible impossible
it's hot uh between the lights and the
80-something degree heat and the
humidity but
most likely it'll be a season review uh
would you ever do a review of dr
horrible sing-along blog
i don't
i do it if someone commissioned me i
don't i don't think i would otherwise
if doctor who did a 180 and said that
the doctor was the timeless child would
you think it would make it better or
worse
neither it would still be stupid just
for a different reason
now instead being in case of you did
this horrible plot thing
to the doctor now will be a case of you
lied about this horrible plot thing why
the hell did you do that
that was pointless so it's bad either
way it just be
the reason why it's bad changes so
that's neither better nor worse that's
just a different flavor of stupid
uh just to tell you but flash season
three has a musical crossover with
supergirl i actually did watch the
musical crossover
also it's a glee reunion and joe's actor
returns to sing
as well as john barrowman and stein's
actor uh ever seen the walter hill movie
the assignment slash
tomboy i saw it on netflix and it's just
so bad no
i have not um
archvillain it robs us of nathaniel's
singing
oh copyright is the council of geeks
arch villain
nice uh did you know michael jackson and
bill cosby were supposed to be
the doctor for the doctor who movie we
dodged some bullets
there um citation needed
if doctor who you know did that noam
chomsky co-signed the document protected
speak
free speech along with jk rowling like a
bunch of people did
and a bunch of them have since claimed
that they wouldn't have signed
it had they known who else was signing
it because the
that document in and of itself it's one
of those things where you read
it unto itself and it's like okay but
then you look at the names underneath
and you realize is what it's really
up to and a bunch of people did say if
i'd known who else was signing this i
wouldn't have signed it
i don't know if chomsky was one of the
people who
said that or not i do know there were
multiple though i don't care either way
i i just i just don't at this point
um have you listened to the good omens
quarantine edition
uh that one needs a reaction video i
haven't i've seen some of the episodes
of staged
uh though that was fun
uh one thing i'm really annoyed about
with this show is
i want to tell some uh i want to tell
some of the ideas but
then again this chat is full of writers
are you afraid we're going to dog pile
you with suggestions
um let's see i've
seen the defense that losing newt uh
it's part of the feminist theme
the argument is that she has been denied
her motherhood then loses her femininity
hair is too short wait what
i you lost me ben you completely lost me
um e.t or poltergeist oh et
absolutely i didn't see poltergeist as a
kid i saw it as an adult and it's
fine um but
you know
uh while we're waiting for the series
did you see that audible did
an adaptation of it of
what you mean of like sandman um
because i did download that i haven't i
haven't listened to it yet
i have so many ghosts like the ones they
wear in hamilton oh
jealous could have been worse
rowling was almost in an episode of
doctor who replacing waters of
mars uh written by gareth roberts of all
people we dodged a bullet like again
citation needed on these things uh
waiting my crew lee wrote thank you note
and business card yes i
am i am actually really far behind
on those that's one of my missions this
week is to try and catch up on
that stuff going out i've got that in
merch bundles to get out the door
um i only finished aero season one
yesterday i'm now watching the boys
season one also planning to watch swamp
thing in the 1990 flash before aero
season two you are
busy rowan my goodness i needed to get
good at networking because
i'm the extrovert who adopts all the
introvert friends and they never meet up
if i didn't arrange it
that would do it a favorite non-force
user in star wars
ham
there you go vera's way too comfortable
as the master
check the discord ah thank you heroin
all right let me get that pulled up i
thought i had it up i don't
so let's
oh that's right because i restarted my
computer forgot that i did that
how are you watching stage that i need
to know well i know that a few weeks ago
episodes were up on youtube they're
probably they've probably been taken
down by now
um
all right here we go i'm not sure you
have ever
discussed dune so not sure if it's if
it's on your fandom radar
but uh if you have seen what do you
think of lynch version and two are you
looking forward to
the the news version um i have seen the
lynch version
it's a mess um
and i am i mean i'm looking forward to
whatever denis villanue
does next he's become one of those
filmmakers i'm like
i don't always love what you do but it's
always interesting and i want to see it
uh probably gonna be there for like 15
minutes have to close tonight oh yep
and then um which of these droids
is better or why crichton or marvin
um
to read about in a story i prefer marvin
because i just i think the way that he
was written and used by
douglas adams was impeccable for someone
who i would actually have to put up with
i would take creighton marvin would get
old
real quick doctor in distress and how
you would rewrite that to be good would
be a challenge uh
i'm not a songwriter i think i can see
chibs as the person who has a more
positive impact on doctor who even if i
like moffat's style more
now only time will tell on that one
everyone forgot the best doctor who
regeneration yours
thank you for that do you like the new
master yes i do
got to go to work remember my cavity
uh thank you very much is bojack too sad
to commission you to watch
i don't know because i haven't seen any
of it all right here's what i will say
at this point probably the only way to
get me to bump it up the list would be
to commission it
i wouldn't turn it down if you did
uh that's cool i just wanted to check i
commissioned that because it's the one
where banks
actually explores the gender switching
properly yeah you mentioned that so i am
curious to see that
will you watch the mulan live action i
might actually because that one actually
looks like it's doing what i would want
these things to do which is to be
a fresh take on the original material as
opposed
to just remaking the movie disney
already made
but you know we'll see
thoughts on mst 3k it's fun
that's kind of it kim possible was a big
influence on me growing up thoughts on
the tune never watched it
i was too old have you seen h bomber
guys sherlock is garbage video i have
uh is a little overstated in that one
but
i mean he's he does he does good work uh
in general after i saw it and after
series four i couldn't enjoy the first
series the first uh
few series anymore i mean that's
uh that's the thing about really
um thorough criticism sometimes it makes
you go oh
i still enjoy the first three series and
even the second episode of the fourth
series of sherlock
um do you have a favorite non-who david
tennant's performance yes
scrooge mcduck close your eyes and
picture an apple then describe what the
apple looks like please
um pass
confused and pass uh no i'm more afraid
of my ideas being stolen
you say to a person who has who has an
author diary up on my other channel
honestly though i think a lot of authors
are overly paranoid
about that not to say that you should
just
spread it everywhere but you know
uh let's see
if next to normal was going to be made
into a movie who would you cast
oh jeez
i would want mostly unknowns in that
part because i would want it
to feel as real as possible
and i mean it's already heightened
reality because of the musical nature of
that
story um so
ideally to me you would ground it in
lesser known cast who it's not so you're
not going like oh hey
it's you know this recognizable person
and i'm not a good person asked for
dream casting anyways my brain doesn't
do that very well
if 13 had a new costume and it was a
dress no
what would you think i would think
please don't
i don't know why i'm asking this but
thought but the thought crossed my mind
like the
i don't think i don't think a dress is
practical for the doctor
just period now
if they ever wanted to do something like
how the doctor put on a tux
to go to um that party
and put not this doctor but whoever the
next
male doctor is in an evening dress for
that
i would be all for it but only on that
one occasion
uh any good age rating for discord
not entirely sure what that question
means watched aliens of london and world
war three recently
remember rose called the doctors so gay
i know i actually completely forgot that
that was weird or not funny was it
supposed to be funny probably was
supposed to be
thoughts on how churchill was presented
in victory of the daleks
as someone who's not huge into churchill
history he seemed
fine i'm gonna have to wrap it up soon
i'm gonna i'm trying to catch up and
burn through
questions gotta go stay cool oh thank
you very much donna it was good to see
you say hi to liz i will
top three ghibli movies i have a video
up on my
ranking of them favorite bond film from
each of the six actors well i haven't
seen the timothy dalton or
um the george lazenby but other than
that
it would be goldfinger
um for your eyes
only goldeneye and
skyfall
uh yeah i was referring to the video i
thought it was good sorry
thoughts on the cat being confirmed as a
as a psychopath
um i haven't seen that i don't remember
that
can you end the video with my cavity
again well we'll see if i can remember
um trying to catch up
where was i
um you did that stream reaching out to
blair white after you did that did
anyone more involved in the online left
discourse tell you
uh that was a bad or dangerous idea
people have comments
saying that well no nobody said
i nobody really said that i shouldn't
have made the response video there were
some people when i expressed the idea
that i would be willing to talk
to her in a non-recorded um
manner that that wouldn't be worth
anything but it
was moot you know that was never gonna
happen anyway
um let's see
what celeb birthday do you share your
birthday with besides yours i have no
idea
not a clue because this is the kind of
thing i just don't care
um my nude answer was not coherent sorry
it's apparently meant to be a criticism
of women
in male genres being written like
men her losing her short hair makes her
look like a man
huh not sure i buy that
uh there's no such thing as too old uh
you're only as old as you feel
well how my back has been feeling lately
i am feeling quite old
uh though i should qualify that as a
boomer writing in 1996 trying to explore
gender switching
like i'll take that into account when i
read it
uh losing newt whom she
uh sort of becoming a surrogate mother
towards is another aspect of femininity
that was stolen from her
probably explaining this badly aren't i
um
like i get i get why they did it
i just don't care what your
justification is it was wrong
it was wrong and stupid and awful and
negated the previous movie so i don't
care what thematic rationalization you
have for it
it was horrible and
nothing you can tell me will convince me
otherwise because no matter what you
tell me i'll go
oh okay it still negates the climax of
the previous film
that doesn't fix the problem i have with
it
was just asking because apparently some
people picture a cartoonish apple some
people picture green apples instead of
red some people can't even do it
i mean i would have pictured a green
apple because that's what i prefer to
eat
uh marvin or
uh or flir ismo ah
em soho um
i feel like i probably get less
irritated with flare
uh and so at least on a personal level
okay one more idea that will happen in
an episode basically the show
is essentially about villains i'll
explain the rest in another comment not
enough space
uh is ford prefect the doctor in
distress
it could be uh least favorite hamilton
song
oh huh
um none of them really stuck out to me
as the
dud so i don't really have an answer for
that
i mean if i if i like re-listen to it
with that in mind i could come up with
an answer but i'm not gonna think of one
um off the top of my head
let's see a multiverse traveler from a
universe where they watch
the show comes in and meets a character
he says how much he loves her and calls
her
precious so she tortures him
um interesting
uh this seems a little weird to ask
but uh but you know any way to be
procrastinating
um build habits is
the best thing that i can advise uh it's
a problem i have too
and i battle it a lot uh what is the
episode with the reformed evil histori
oh it was the episode with the
reformed evil historical figures oh
that's right do we consider that
confirmed though because like the like
all of the
wasn't all of the psychological
information coming from a guy who turned
out to be the secret villain
but i mean like i buy that he's a cat
cats are psychopaths
would you ever watch my little pony
friendship as magic if somebody paid me
uh what is your favorite episode of
torchwood mine is countryside that one
freaks me out i mean
i lump um children on earth as
one story so i would probably say that
happy birthday to me tomorrow good night
have a ha have a good birthday do you
prefer uh
green or red grapes green red ones
they something i don't know they don't
taste right to me
sorry i wasn't trying to get you to
change your mind just thought it might
be interesting to mention
explanation is not justification i get
it yes thank you for saying that
that is one of that is one of the drums
that i will never stop beating
like when i tell people i don't like
something like well here's what it means
i'm like
it's not a question of whether i i know
what it means i
don't like it
[Music]
wait before i go rest in peace reaches
phil then i
regis was not a guy i i really um i
really knew all that much about
is youtube your main job well at the
moment youtube's my only job because i
was laid off
so um technically it's not really enough
to cover my bills
though so um working on that how would
you fix the simpsons or do you think
it's actually all right even if it's
less popular than once it was see i
don't know the current status of the
simpsons because i haven't watched it in
years
so i i couldn't actually tell you
uh what's your favorite song from
hamilton favorite
was probably
it was it would have been either
um you'll be back or
um what did i miss i like both of those
a lot
have you seen the elephant man i have
not not in its entirety i've seen bits
and pieces
uh i actually enjoyed the previous
season of the simpsons did you hear
olivia coleman will guest star in the
upcoming season i mean her and everybody
else
like it is it even a mark of anything to
guest on the simpsons anymore
i feel like they're running out of
celebrities oh my goodness i've actually
caught up
did you hear the phantom of the opera
closing the west end i didn't
huh rank youtube against your previous
employers
um about on par
about as transparent as my old employers
were
uh would you watch my show when it's
done i'd give it a shot
uh
it's enough to pay my bills yet gathers
cash for doctor in distress episode fun
what would be your ideal sci-fi
storyline if you could have
any desired crossover um
[Music]
oh i don't know because like i'm not i'm
not i'm actually not that big of a
crossover person
by nature have you seen solaris which do
you prefer us or
russian i have only seen the us version
and i didn't care that much for it
have you heard of a 2004 film called
collateral not only have i heard of it
it's on my list of films to do for good
movie
bad ending
so see how much heat i get for that one
how would you describe the films of
sergio leone
um as movies that i have only seen like
one of and i don't even remember which
one now
andrew lloyd webber or steven sondheim
oh
boy that is tough like lord
lloyd webber when he's good i do like
him more but sondheim is
good more frequently
uh the simpsons is what doctor who is
for british actors you can't call
yourself a true american actor
until you've been on the simpsons that
sounds about right
i used to enjoy the cat in the hat movie
when i was a kid i'm sorry
did your parents not like you
good movie bad ending uh for the whole
of human existence
it's the 10th anniversary of sherlock do
you have any words to say about it on
its anniversary
it was mostly good
charlie heaton jonathan from stranger
things was meant to play the elephant
man for a tv adaptation and people were
up in arms
why would they be up in arms about that
i mean the
i'm not i'm not personally aware
they could look and it would be nice if
they did
but i'm not personally aware of any
working actors with anything
close to the physical condition
that john merrick had so
unless you found an actor who
did have some and even if you did like
we know what john merrick looked like
so even if you did it would probably
still be prosthetically
modified to more closely resemble
exactly how we know he looked
based off you know the the
images and everything else we have of
him
so unless you found an actor with a
similar physical condition
anyone you get is gonna have to be
buried under prosthetics
so that
i'm not entirely sure what they would
have been up in arms about
unless the unless there was actually a
campaign to get
a an actor with uh with a similar
physical
condition in the part which actually i
would be all in favor of
i'm not aware of any working actors with
anything
close to his physical condition though
so that would be a hunt and beyond that
i'd like to see them undergo
i don't know how fruitful it would be
though
then again i'm not a casting agent so
what the heck do i know
favorite ducktales character um
that's scrooge yeah it's gotta be
scrooge especially in the new one
uh i did actually enjoy cutting the hat
but i never had the dr seuss books read
to me so i didn't have anything better
to compare to
oh yeah that would do it
great with the fireflies always makes me
cry grave of the fireflies
is sadness condensed
into it's just oh
man that thing is brutal i've yet to
mention to you that i love jim carrey's
grinch ooh
my parents were rather neutral about me
by the way oh that tracks
um i do have to wrap it up soon folks
that's my point the only actor i can
think of is the one from under the skin
oh yeah that's right see i've forgotten
see under the skin is a movie that like
i vividly remember certain parts but
big swads of it my brain has tried to
expunge because that movie
deeply unsettled me
like to my core that movie unsettled me
so i i'd actually forgotten about him
you know it that would work
if like if they could get him how to fix
the pirates of the caribbean franchise
stop after the third one there you go
i actually think the third one is
underrated
whether or not you have any interest in
watching it do you uh did you know that
zach caffron has his own travel
documentary series on netflix
yes i was aware i saw trailers
all right i do have to wrap it up
i've gone a little longer than uh
normally planned
but thank you all for tuning in
uh if you are anywhere and nearly
as overheated as i am i hope you managed
to stay cool
um so i hope
that uh you are being well being
safe it's it's still important
i've got a jar a dirt
um so thank you for tuning in
and please remember that you are
beautiful
you are valid and you are loved
you're the council i just run the
meetings
have a good night everybody